[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد ذلك لم يكن هناك انقطاع
المرة الأولى المتوقعة على وجه التحديد فقط
يحق لقمع المصالح
الروبوت المكتوب لا يزال مفتوحًا
أعتقد في بعض الأحيان الحساسية و
اقول يدلي بصوت جيد
انا اعلانك
مسألة صغيرة من السياسة
و 2
[موسيقى]
مبيض الشوكولاتة كريستين ولكن وبعد
كان 70 مليون اللمسة الأخيرة
مايكل سومر يوروفايتر المواقع الفرعية
وتحصل على الكثير من الحلويات أو الرسائل
ملك
لديك
والبني فقط بهدوء في الأماكن
يربط
لذلك أنت لا تقول نعم على
موقف لفعل شيء ما
على الرغم من أنه كان في الساحة عن طريق البريد
لكن لا توجد فرصة هنا
سيعرف المرء عندما يأتون الآن
سيكون الأمر دائمًا مثيرًا
في جميع أنحاء العالم أن المحلات التجارية فوق كل شيء
التواصل أو تكوين صداقات يعني أن تذهب
الأخبار الجيدة لا تسير على ما يرام
قد يكون ببساطة غائبًا في مكان آخر
محافظ ولا يتحدث
يمكنه المواكبة في بكين وأنت
حسناً أنا تلك برلين التسول
كل ذلك مع التجارة والبريد
استدارة
والأولاد ذوو اللياقة البدنية
الكوماندوز المهني للطلاب في تاكسي الحلقة
كان كينيدي مع طوني هوك في سيدني
هذا كل ما حصل
حسنا نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم
كل منظور يعني المتاجرة
خلفية اشتكى لدينا
فالنسيا في المنزل
الحقيقة هي أنه لا يزال لدينا القليل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]